[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to the what
podcast i'm barry they're in the middle
in the pabst blue ribbon hat as always
is lord taco he's an actual lord and
we've explained that many times
and this week you'll notice that brad is
not with us
as we explained last week brad and
hillary are moving from
um
moving from new orleans to new york uh
he's taking a job up there
obviously we wish him well that i know
they got there safely
glad to hear that
um
and um
he'll be back as soon as he can but
with us is uh a special guest who you
guys most of you guys will probably no
doubt recognize the name
pondo we're going to talk uh he's a
veteran as we are we're going to talk
about his experience at bonnaroo and
how excited he is to be back on the farm
and what he's looking forward to
uh just get another uh another take from
it so pando thanks again for doing this
all right no problem uh i was
hitchhiking and uh you know i know
brad's not here this week i was
hitchhiking and this guy on a pbr hat
was driving by saying he wanted the
people to talk to and he couldn't find
anybody and i said well i'll do it and
he said no we're not taking you and then
i slipped him at 20 and hey here i am
wow that's amazing how it works
is 20 bucks yeah that's right
that's the level of screening that's
right yeah
it it's been a while since we've been on
a farm um i think the one thing i think
that stands out for everybody at least
from my point of view is the fact that
we're actually getting a chance to go
back to something that we enjoy
and that we love and we cherish
for people who have gone multiple times
this has become like
an event a rite of passage each year
going to bonnaroo is like a family
reunion or like meeting loved ones that
you haven't seen in a long time it's so
powerful and so
just energizing it's like my body
permanently knows when june is it's like
my brain will sit there and say okay
it's it's march it's april once may
comes around the brain starts working a
little bit and then june comes if i hear
the word manchester united on tv i'm not
thinking soccer drop the united i'm
thinking bonnaroo the farm and we're
heading there so are you guys super
excited about being back
yeah yeah
i mean i'm glad you set it up that way
because that's kind of
i think i i said on the last show that
i have developed sort of a rhythm you
know throughout the year and like you
said when you hit may for us it starts
for me it starts in january with the
lineup release
uh you know and because of this podcast
um
even before we started doing the podcast
i think we were talking about it year
round
and in fact that's why we started the
podcast because i think brad and i
said you know this is nuts we're talking
about an event that happens four days
you know then out of the year in june
uh and we're talking about it and if we
are others probably are as well
so that's why we started this but
there definitely had become a rhythm you
know january
you start looking at that lineup you
spend the next several weeks talking
about it
you hit may or even a little earlier and
you start thinking i need to get all my
equipment out i need to make sure the
rats haven't eaten holes in it and i
know where it is
you know and that i didn't leave the
batteries in anything um
start buying supplies you know what am i
going to take this year that i didn't
have last year
i mean all those things start playing in
and not having that well we did last
year
we very much did everyone was packed up
and
and ready but it still kind of
kind of left a little hole maybe what
what's the last two years been like for
you well let's go back first real quick
when did you start going how many years
have you been going i have been going
nonstop since 2008. the story and it
kind of goes with the viking horns and
the clock um i didn't i didn't notice
what do you do really
well
i'll tell you something this is a secret
girls love a nice big clock
make sure you had a l in there you get
sexual
especially at work i know two jobs
anyways uh 2008 um
was the first year that i went and me
and a good friend of mine went and with
some other people and we had gone to
woodstock 99
and he dressed up as a psychedelic
cowboy and he got on the dvd
so we're going to go to bother and he
goes it's your turn and at that time
flavor flav was a rapper real popular
and he wore
viking horns and guess what else
clock
so i went and i established kind of the
alter ego of pondo and i said you know
it'd be really great if we started
something called the pondo army
and originally it was more of a rib or a
gag or something and then i noticed
like
people
online i was on a website called emperor
were going you're going to wear the
outfit again next year right and i'm
like
oh god i had never even thought about it
and then i said well if we're going to
do that let's develop this pondo army
into something and what the ponder army
states is is that
let's say for example barry likes heavy
metal and we know lord taco loves uh
zambia and his pam flute and let's say i
listen to britney spears he's the master
well i agree we may not like each
other's music but we'll respect it i'm
never gonna dog you for what you listen
to because to me if we can all get along
musically just imagine how much we could
accomplish in this world things are
always going to be different you're
always going to have different opinion
but be willing to respect it and embrace
each other and we'll all do it
collectively together and if you can do
that and if we could get some of these
important people to do it man this place
would be a much better place and that's
how the whole thing started and i passed
out pondo army membership cards every
year so if you see me come up to me and
say i want my card i'll give you my card
but for the past two years
i've been able to pass them out so every
year since 2009 didn't do it the first
year but ever since you i've been
passing out those cards and some people
treat it like a where's waldo they'll be
like man i look for you all weekend
because you know it's 700 acres so
there's a lot of dang space
and i'm like it boggles my mind because
i'm thinking why in the hell
would anybody spend four days looking
for me i wouldn't i mean i don't own
mirrors in my house for a reason because
i look like this guys
all right so i started in 07 i went to
the first one for the first day and then
i've been going ever since since 07.
the clock
when you when you mentioned uh flava
flav now i got to tell it so the day
after their performance
in the media tent janine garofalo who
was one of the comics there
uh was doing the media event and she
said did you guys hear what flava flav
said like i mean what comic the insult
dog said last night in the comedy tent
and we're like no i mean some people had
but you know who insult the comedy
right right right yeah try them yeah try
excuse me yeah try up the insult yeah i
knew i had that somewhere
convoluted but he said you know why he
wears that clock
so that uh he can tell how far back he
set the civil rights movement
that's all anybody was talking about
that whole next day it's so funny
um
you know i'm not at all surprised by
your story i i mean
i am because it's hard for people who
have never been to bonnaroo to
understand why that's not so surprising
the fact that you know you created
something
and people are into it
there's something about that event that
brings people together you've said if we
can come together
by music every time i leave there
i say to everybody why can't we be like
this year round yes
you know yes
or or take it home with you well yeah
just and
why i mean everything from
you know if if you if you see a piece of
trash pick it up and throw it away don't
just add to it i mean and certainly
don't just step over it pick it up yeah
it's simple and if everybody does it
you know the place is pretty clean
and treat people kindly you know i've
told the story many many my first time
going up there
standing in line and it's as you said it
you know at that time it was closer to
90 000 people it was 80 000
uh when it sold out and so you you know
you think it's crowded uh people it's
hot
people are gonna be short-tempered but i
mean i can remember standing in line and
people would say oh i forgot something
and they'd leave and come back and
everybody like go ahead man get back
you never seen that anywhere else you're
like whoa
yeah i mean that was stunning and then
you know i i thought i'd go buy the lost
and found
just to see what was lost and what was
found and some guy was there getting his
wallet he'd lost it the night before in
center in the in the main stage
area you know
crowded is and somebody had turned it in
he was like everything's in it all my
money still wow
somebody found it
made the trip you know to turn it in and
it was like only at bonnaroo
you know those kind of things stuck out
to me and
they have stood with me i've i've only
seen
i was able to say i've never seen a
cross word until the last one and there
were two volunteers they were a husband
and wife and they'd
probably been at about hour 11 and a
half of their 12-hour shift and i was
not having it it even started he started
yelling at her about go get me a coke or
water or something that's the only only
crossword i've ever
ever seen or heard
that's just you know treat people the
way you want to be treated it's the code
right right it's funny that you bring up
lost and found because one year i went
by and lord taco was there and lost and
found and nobody was playing them nobody
wanted to pick him up everyone said he's
always been lost so you know i don't
know i don't know what happened with
that they had him in that cardboard box
yeah yeah yeah kind of where we picked
him i think brad
yeah don't no one else wanted to admit
to knowing me so well and brad waited
till monday morning because he knew he
could get him cheap
that is one of my favorite things too on
monday morning when you're leaving look
at everybody because if you want to see
what an extra on the walking dead looks
like that is it because everybody's like
well they look like i look now so i'm
just looking that's really not no
stretch for me
yeah monday morning or sunday morning
because sunday i'm an early riser i get
up and it always amazes me those people
who go all night long on saturday
and when the sun's coming up i'm getting
up going to get coffee and they're going
to their tent
yeah and i'm thinking you're not going
to sleep long it's sun's up you know
yeah that's it's it's
about to be miserable uh how many people
do you go first of all where do you come
from okay i came from a little town
called henderson kentucky we're near
evansville indiana and
henderson kentucky is actually famous
for absolutely nothing so it works out
pretty well that i get it's about a
three and a half hour drive i've gone
with as many as six but now we have four
that uh we
that all together now um one of my best
friends dave he goes with me and and the
ages are crazy because i just turned 48
my birthday was saturday uh
then my best friend he's 47
he goes
and uh then we got a woman who's 63
maybe 64. if i get her age wrong if i
get cindy's age wrong she'll come back
and kill me so i'll just say she's 49.
and then we have her grandson who's 19
braden he goes and then a really special
friend of mine whose nickname is
sweetness i'm gonna try to get her to go
next year
um it's weird because you brought up
something
i try to explain and sell people on
bonnaroo and until you go you can't do
it it's like the grand canyon
you try to explain the grand canyon it's
big it's a lot of rocks you can explain
it forever but until you go and actually
see it you know nothing about the grand
canyon and bonnaroo is such a unique
experience for everybody and the one
thing that i love
is
both you guys could go see
totally different sets than me
you could get up early like i could be
one of those strugglers coming back
right we could have totally different
experiences and still absolutely love
every second of it and we could share
those experiences and i try to explain
people people that bothering is
something you have to experience
watching it on tv watching it online
it's great there's nothing wrong with
that but it's not being there and that's
one thing i can say that separates this
festival from so many others
yeah i totally agree i mean i i'll ask
rice while you're sitting there because
this will be
what four
for you 18
18 was my first one i went to 18 and 19.
and then i went to exit 111 which i get
doesn't really count but that's the last
time i was on the farm right and and and
uh taco is a little bit of an outlier
because he loves to camp in fact he's in
in the bus and that's what he camps in
that he does that on the regular
um i camp once a year
and it's at bonnaroo once a year
yeah and prior to 07 that's the reason i
didn't go in two through six is the idea
of sleeping on the you know on in a
field in manchester tennessee yeah right
what's in manchester especially you know
at that time to be honest you know
mostly jam bands and and also
you know i was uh late and
later in life with children and
you know it just was not in nowhere on
my radar um i i knew from that first
visit how cool it was
right and how different it was
but
the camping part of it
and and i i say that because that's
usually what you get when you mention it
to anybody who's never been
yeah and that's that's what sold me on
it yeah well that sold you and that
turns a lot of people i mean i can't
tell you how many times i've said i go
to bonnaroo every year and people look
at me and they say you camp
did you sleep in a tent you know surely
you get a hotel room
i'm like no i i don't in fact i don't
know about you panda you may not have
had have the opportunity but like brad
leaves the site
every day
i don't want to ever leave when i'm
there i it breaks some sort of magic
spell or something one of my best
friends said something and it got
with first stop of leaving and secondly
with going to camp
every time you go to camp or you leave
you risk
missing something
in 2008 the coral reefers were playing
in center room
and we are
sitting at camp and everybody's kind of
tired nobody wants to go in and
everything i said let's wait and go in
we go in
and we miss some guy that played with
them some guy named jimmy last name
buffett yeah so by us being lazy and not
wanting to go in we miss jimmy buffett i
mean that's a once-in-a-lifetime
experience for me you know and like
i tell everybody when you're at if you
leave and you go to the hotel
or and you do a lot of media a lot of my
friends that that take for do the
photography thing will go to the hotel
and and i'll say
you risk missing something well it's
three o'clock in the morning i said at
bonnaroo you risk missing something at
three o'clock in the morning so it's
just you know well in my case it's not
just a show that i might miss or a star
i might miss a great time at camp at
three
brad and i were laughing uh this past
weekend not during the show
we met downtown for a couple of beers
with another campmate
and we just laughed about you know the
stories that we
picking on each other at midnight you
know or later
right that's
that's the part that
i can't
i can't explain to people who you know
when i say i go to bonnaroo they say you
sleep in a tent yeah well
as we've said on here many many times we
bring our own carpet we have a ginormous
tent we have a bloody mary tent
it's nice
you know we do it upright we have a
picket fence it's nice it's not like
we're sleeping in mud which right i
think for some reason that's the image
they don't understand
the 24-hour
ness
and it becomes a community you bond with
your neighbors you'll end up talking to
them and maybe they know somebody that
you should see that you've never thought
about oh absolutely there was one year
that we went i don't remember there was
a
there was a group that was playing i
remember who it was and they're like
have you seen them before and i said no
you should really check them out we went
and they were like one of the top three
acts we saw the whole weekend
and it's such an um
it's such an amazing feeling because
then you're like oh wow i didn't know
about them and i found out about them
and
and
i think especially for people like me
that are older i think another drawback
now is a lot of people say well i don't
know people on the lineup or i don't
know as much of the light because it's
younger
explore a little bit take take take one
day out of your schedule and just go
through spotify or do something like
that and explore and i said you might
find that you're gonna find
five acts you knew nothing about that
all of a sudden you're just dying to see
yeah that's i again for me
the importance of this festival in my
life and i'm not overstating that
is as a as an entertainment writer
that's i've from since about 1982
you know i've written about music i've
reviewed shows
uh but quite honestly it was all arena
shows and small venue shows that i was
going to and there was a lot of sameness
it was the same show you know they're
gonna do three songs they're gonna say
hello chattanooga fifth song they're
gonna use the band they're gonna tell a
bad joke
you know they're gonna do two encores
it's gonna be 90 minutes to the minute
and you're gonna go home it didn't
matter if it was a rat well a rap show
those were different but a country show
or a rock show or whatever it was you
could tell
management you know they had a lot of
the same choreographers and managers it
was just sameness
bonnaroo changed all that for me
in that
not just me but everybody who went
suddenly just what you said pondo that
became the game was to discover the next
favorite band
you know if you could turn one of your
buddies onto it
that was double bonus right right
yeah that's exactly right and
that's a huge part of it for all of us
and the other part of it for us and i
don't know how you and your group
is but we almost never attend the same
show and we if we do we never go
together
what what we usually do is
we have a a young the one that's 19 we
don't know where he's going to go he's
he's he'll do a little bit of edm
probably more than we will and and then
like usually uh his grand grandmother
will go with him sometimes and then
usually me and my best friend will go to
a show but a lot of times on super jam
night that's where we get split up
because
super jam is so special and so unique
and
this year the 1984 aspect of it's gonna
be just you know so we we might all go
to that show but a lot of times
um
you know it it's what's pretty amazing
is
to brag on on cindy who is
60-ish
uh i have never been in the pit for a
headliner and i've gone since 2008
she's gone i think five or six times and
she's already been in the pit for two
headliners and she's 60-ish so
you know it's like it's like there's
literally something for everybody one
thing i did want to touch on real quick
is it has been two years
and
anybody who follows me on twitter and if
you don't i will do a shameless plug at
pondo knows best i might handle on
twitter
and i do follow both of you gentlemen
and lord taco good lord if you could
understand his tweets
please someone give me a book and
and decipher some of that stuff
especially at like two in the morning
after i've had some liquid courage but
it doesn't matter what time of day it is
you'll have to explain that
that's the problem um
just
in the past year alone for me has been
absolutely
horrific i i know everybody's had
situations
but um
last year uh august 31st my mom passed
away from copen i was in the hospital
covenant both of us had been vaccinated
to the fullest extent at that time
and um
doctor come in there while i was in
there and told me you have a 30 chance
to live well i found out later that that
was inflated i wasn't supposed to make
it
uh so my mom passed away and then in
january i got
readmitted to the hospital for uh
dehydration
and that was because i was still sick
from after effects of coven they
happened to do a ct scan and they found
a mass on my left kidney
so i had cancer of the kidney and uh
i tell everybody i said man i must have
had a hell of a party because i woke up
next day i'm missing a kidney they had
to take the whole kidney out and so it
and and there's been a bunch of other
small things that have gone along with
it and so this year
i'm gonna appreciate bonnaroo
more than i ever have
uh whenever we're on that long road
going in
and i got goosebumps talking about it
now i will probably start crying
and the moment we park that car and get
out and i see that grass
and i
feel the sun on me
and i see the ferris wheel and i see
everything and everybody going every
which way
and people laughing and you can probably
already smell the porta-potties that are
outside the center
right that
moment
is probably going to be one of the best
moments
of bonnaroo ever and i'm actually
probably expecting to break down and cry
for a while i'll probably be no good for
about 10 or 15 minutes and then i'll get
back in pondo mode and i'll be ready to
go
but
i have missed that place so much
it has become a fabric of my life
and
you know
you talked about four days earlier you
know four days out of the year you go
and do this most of the year i do i
don't wear this mostly here
i work at uh i work at an auto parts
factory well except recently since i
lost my kidney i haven't been there
because i've been out for fla but
you don't know how many people do not
know me as brian
they know me as pondo they will see me
out places i will go to nashville or
whatever hey pondo i'm like wow and they
recognized me without the ridiculous get
up
and
it's amazing that this is a place where
you can go let your hair down well taco
doesn't have much hair so we'll let that
go i just got a haircut
and be whatever you want to be for a few
days let go of everything at home
plug out
and just go and have the best amazing
time and think about how many people
you've met at this festival
well not just uh but at the events that
we've had uh tacos
stories of running into people like you
just said out and they recognize his
voice or the hat or something brad ran
into
you know a listener two weeks in two
weekends ago down in new orleans yeah it
happens but beyond that is
uh people like you
obviously uh uh
the guys at rue ham and and uh charlotte
and daniel with the rewboss i mean we
speak
fairly regularly
you know um
almost daily become friends with all of
these people and keep up through reddit
or
emails or texts or whatever it goes
beyond
um
you know
a website or whatever it's right it's
personal these are people that care
about right um
yeah we understand we don't get into it
too much but it has been a tough year
for for all of us as well
and that this event this
weekend
um in fact i started writing a column
for one of the magazines we do trying to
talk about
this
and typically when i get the first
sentence i i'm essentially done i've
written three of them already i've
completely restarted twice which is very
rare
for me because it just when i get down
to a certain
point i'm like i
i haven't said anything that i wanted to
say yet you know what i mean because it
has to be a a certain
length so it's remarkable to me
it's remarkable to me that five years in
and in year three of an event that
hasn't happened we still are talking
about it correct
but again as i said earlier
i'm not surprised it is when it's
surprising when you say it out loud
like that
but to you and and taco and and brad and
everybody else it's not at all
surprising because i mean how many times
have you listened to our podcast or
someone else's and had a uh you know
somebody call in and say oh my friends
are so tired of me talking about
bonnaroo
yeah
all year long
it's like i was trying to tell i
explained what your podcast was about
one day and i was telling some friends i
said you gotta listen to the what
podcast and they're like the what i said
precisely and they said is this abbot
costello i said no it's the what podcast
it took a few took a few go arounds but
i said
trust me if you listen you will gather
so much information
and you might wear a pbr hat in the
future that's right
let me know
we we are well aware it's a stupid name
but it made perfect sense when we
conceived it right
yes
as you know the what you know the way
they named the stages the what which
this that and the other and uh when we
reached out to bonnaroo and said hey
we're we think we want to start this
podcast they said we're thrilled
please do but you can't use uh bonnaroo
in your url or you can't use any of our
graphics so
you know and of course we're thinking
it'll be what three months at best yeah
we we thought one season and we'll be
done yeah so you know see ya and
anyway
it works and uh
taco has done as i've said the last
couple shows done a terrific job with
our website
which by the way i wanted to mention we
got a i got a lot of emails from people
who said hey i'd love to have some of
the stuff from your basement
and i'm 100 serious you know but buy a
t-shirt or something just so we can kind
of cover the costs and uh okay
i've started a pile and uh
yeah i'm glad to get shameful
shameless plug the whole point for me is
to empty this basement out of stuff
[Laughter]
but that was a lot of fun and it was fun
getting uh getting emails from
from people um
so
what are you i mean you you said really
and and happy birthday and i'm glad
you're better
absolutely i mean i was kind of
following that i wasn't going to bring
it up publicly unless you wanted to well
this is my best birthday present right
here
yeah you come on the what podcast i mean
happy birthday right yeah glad we could
do it thank you
i want to go back and ask
i'm intrigued by the the grandmother and
grandson going um i've been with both of
my kids
and i remember the first year my son was
he would have graduated high school
and i was like bad news man dad's going
to be there too and he's like i don't
care you know
i thought he would you know i'd be harsh
in his mellow kind of thing but yeah i
was just trying to imagine i was just
trying to imagine me at bonnaroo with my
grandmother like i just i know right
first off first off i i definitely want
to let you guys know this
cindy
is not your typical grandma she is
had to be the case
she's uh
like i said she's been in the pit twice
she's a ma amazing woman um
she is a breast cancer survivor and
she goes out and she parties just as
hard as anybody else there and braden
is 19 got a good got a good head on his
shoulders
and
introduced her like as soon as as soon
as the lineup comes out he'll be like
okay we're going to go see this this and
this
she'll play something he'll play
something for her and you're like
she's like no no no you're going to go
see that i'm not going to go but then
she'll hear something like i think this
year
she heard uh nathaniel wright live in
the night sweats and she wasn't real
familiar with them and then she's like
wait a minute we're gonna go see them
and so you know and it's it's an
it again shows the dynamic where you can
literally
be pretty much as long as you're old
enough to go and that's that's the
subject for you know another day but
anybody can go uh from ages
you know i remember when the bottom
grannies went i don't know if you guys
were familiar with them they were yeah
i got to meet them all and they were
amazing and i watched earth winning fire
with them right in front of me and you
know um you have literally four grandmas
sit there right in front of me and i'm
talking to them and they're enjoying
every minute of it of course they go at
night you know that they they come in
they don't care but that's just like
amazing so
it's literally a festival for everybody
the one thing that i will say that that
you have brought up a couple of times
it's not a festival it's an event
and i've used that line a couple of
times so i don't know if i picked it up
from you or we stole it from someone
else but that's the best way to put it
it's not in the fest it's not a festival
it's an event and now with the plaza is
going on
there's so much going on
that it truly is an event because
there's stuff everywhere now
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it
i think that's really cool i i can't
imagine being able to go with a
grandparent or or a grandson
a grandchild and you know either way is
really cool to be able to share
something like that um
but the other thing we've said is the
only the only real couple of rules
uh and i've had parents ask me before
because you know they'll say you go
every year my kid wants to go
you know their high school age or
whatever my only thing is if they're the
type of person who
finds trouble
they'll find trouble sure if they're a
level-headed mature kid they won't have
any trouble at all
again they people take care of each
other
um
you know but if you're just that kind of
kid that somehow always seems to be in
trouble
you can find it there but you can find
it anywhere
the other thing and we've said it on
here many times is
don't come with a spouse or a
significant other unless you're both
really into it
because it it's not a halfway
is that a true statement
it's not a it's not a test the water
kind of event is it correct
yeah correct
uh come ready to have fun the whole time
and explore my point about us not going
to the shows together is not that we
don't like each other but it's that
it's it's goes along the same lines is
if taco says i want to go see nathaniel
and i don't
right he's not feeling guilty and i'm
not feeling guilty you know i'm not i'm
not gonna mope and pout and he's not
either
go have fun and and we'll meet back and
that's that's
our whole group is that way and i think
it's really been important awesome
that everybody understands that
one thing i want to mention just in case
people are new to your podcast which by
the way
if you're not listening on a regular
basis please do because i have learned
countless things from uh you know brad's
not here but all of you guys have taught
me something i'm not wearing a pbr hat
though um the one thing that bonnaroo
has
i i'm not a drug user i i don't and i
don't participate and i usually don't
drink when i'm there but they have a
good policy there of a
you know
if you see somebody messed up or you're
with a friend who's messed up who's done
something maybe they shouldn't have or
has party too hard
they have the you know just just get get
them there get them some help they're
not right there to judge they're there
to try to get you better and i love that
policy because especially with edm
becoming way popular now and a lot of
people associate drugs with edm and
that's that's i think a stereotype maybe
it shouldn't be
but
the you know
don't ask
what what's going on they just want to
help and
the not judging is something that
i think makes that festival
really really good especially for people
who maybe have a tendency to do things
that they shouldn't do i'm not
suggesting at all you guys need to go
get messed up or something like that but
if you see somebody who needs help and
you're afraid i don't want to take them
because they're going to get in trouble
for being on drugs no
help them because by helping them you're
going to keep them out of a situation
where maybe
they can get help and enjoy the festival
and maybe not get sick or perhaps even
worse that's right
yeah that
again
the only real rule in my opinion is
don't be an idiot don't don't make them
do something to you they don't want to
do right they don't want to kick you out
they don't want to arrest you they don't
want you to be sick
and they certainly don't want you to you
know die
um
so yeah take care of yourself and i you
know i
the extra days and the fact that we have
not been there for a while
really has me worried about people
hitting it going too hard that that
that's why i said that because i'm
really worried about that yeah me too me
too i mean i your point about seeing the
grass and feeling the sign i'm i'm the
same way
and i know even in in the last time we
were there you know we
would we say don't don't go hard on that
wednesday and then all three of us went
pretty hard on that one
yeah i was guilty of that too yeah which
makes thursday terrible and half a
friday terrible you know i think about
it as a it's a it's a marathon
but i am very worried because we've been
so pent up
uh for so long you know it's going to
feel like free at last kind of ready to
go kind of thing so take care of each
other
you know really be considerate of that
um what are the other lessons that you
that you've learned um
you know you you've been there as many
times as i have and every one of them
is different but there are definitely
some things
uh both from the camping and pacing
myself and
food and all of that you mentioned i
don't do uh i don't do drugs i wish i
did because that would be the perfect
place i've always said that yeah me too
i've always said if i did drugs because
everybody looks at the outfit and they
assume so i get offered like all kinds
like hey man here's this here's this one
no no i'm good no no i'm good
you're not going anywhere you're not
driving right right
that's great
everything is there it's like i do good
walking back to camp just on soda so i
don't know what i would do if i was too
messed up and that's the same with
everybody think god must be like a
week-long partying and drinking i'm like
nope one word for two words
porta-potties
true
i do have i do have a couple of simple
rules that i tell everybody
one is pace yourself it is not a sprint
it's a marathon
if you want a drink that's fine but
drink in moderation don't
don't sit there and say okay let's just
doubt because like you got you brought
up
thursday and friday you're miserable and
you end up missing sets and you you end
up having nice trips to porta potties uh
two just just that that's if you're
thinking about having that last shot or
whatever just consider
porta potties all morning long right
right because you don't want to be in
there before they're cleaned unless you
want to go into all the way in the
center room um two
uh
make yourself a schedule and don't worry
about it
yeah decide who you want to see and if
you miss somebody i promise you it's not
the end of the world i hate when i see
these people well i'm going to spend 30
minutes at this show and 10 minutes at
this show and five minutes of this show
you know what you're going to see you're
going to see a lot of dust walking back
and forth yeah that's right
one thing i'll tell everybody else
make friends with your neighbors
because nine times out of ten they will
have something that you forgot you're
like oh i forgot that in your name and
your neighbors got and it makes yourself
a community also it helps against people
being around your site that maybe
shouldn't be you know like if i say hey
these are the four people we're gonna
have here and your neighbor says well
these are the three people and you come
back and you see some people that
shouldn't be there you know they
shouldn't be there so that might even
help you out a little bit um i tell
everybody to pack a sharpie because you
never know you might run into lord taco
and you might want to dang an autograph
somewhere you know you never know who
you'll run into in a cinema room i bet a
couple of famous people in center road
had him sign a shirt or two
the last thing that i tell everybody is
your main goal there is to have fun and
a good time
and if you don't feel like you're having
fun or a good time then you could
probably do something else
you brought it up if you're at a show
and it's you're just not feeling it
there are probably at least three or
four or five other acts playing and with
the plazas all other things going
there's plenty to do and you can go off
by yourself you don't have to have
somebody attached to your hip
right yeah yeah i recommend uh taking
some time and just going off by yourself
yeah away from the group
i haven't thought about it that way pono
but that's a that's
we've been saying the same thing but not
only you know don't be somebody else's
dead weight
uh you know don't don't bring them down
if they want to go somewhere else and
don't feel bad if you want to go
somewhere else go do it there's there's
more than enough to do and you'll meet
back up
at some point you know don't get your
feelings hurt i tell everybody a good
meet-up spot if you need a meet-up spot
the clock tower is always there with the
or it's not a clock tower anymore now
it's the bonnaroo tower you could always
meet right there at a certain time and
you go there you're easy to be seen and
that makes it easier
uh
find a spot or in front of the ferris
wheel or something like that or or if
both of you can get back to camp and
you're not directionally challenged meet
back at camp um i know for some people
it's difficult because if you're like a
40-minute walk maybe you don't want to
do that maybe you want to meet back up
don't be afraid to go off on your own
because you might find something amazing
going on that you never would have found
otherwise
yeah if you are in a group two along
those lines uh when you get there walk
around as best you can get the lay of
the land and and take visual markers
write them down if you have to it's a
huge place
uh you know we we've been there enough i
i feel like i could
i won't get lost i know where i am
but when you first arrive it's
overwhelming
and it looks completely different at
three in the afternoon than it does at
three in the morning yes
so get your visual markers and also uh
consider your phones are probably not
gonna work
right i would go ahead and assume
that your phones are not going to work
so if you you know you leave your
buddies and say i'll text you where i am
in an hour
they may get it in an hour they may not
or they might get it in five hours
i do that for you know from a work
standpoint i leave i leave here with a
whole list of things i'm gonna do i'm
gonna send updates every hour and
pictures and
it never works you know maybe in the
morning and that's about it only because
i get up before everyone else so just
you know bank on that so figure out some
way to communicate
you know if you're there with
a large group or you're there with kids
or whatever you know we're going to meet
at such and such a place like you said
the clock tower or the ferris wheel or
um
the mushroom the water fountain you know
whatever there are plenty of
locations and you'll figure out they're
they're central to where you're mostly
gonna be
um we've talked a long time about what
to bring and those sorts of things uh
for the most part i think
you know bring bring you're probably
gonna want to bring less than what you
think yep you know there oh absolutely
especially now
[Music]
in the last several years with the the
stores and the on-site vendors and all
that if you forget something
you can get it
sure you know it may cost an arm and a
leg but it may cost more than you want
to spend but you can you're not going to
be without and the food is really good
and i haven't found the food to be
outrageously expensive plus you're not
going to want to eat three huge meals a
day
because again
porta potties
i gotta give a shout out to to my guys
at roadie rolls uh they do a food truck
at the gourmet food truck
roadie rolls their farm to table uh
corey and his gang are there every year
they're amazing people i've actually
gone on the truck and made a roadie roll
for myself at bonnaroo
uh they're they're located in charleston
and atlanta get a chance to visit their
green truck please do tell them pondo
sent you it's amazing food if you don't
know what a roadie is or what what a
roadie is or a roadie roll is look it up
they do have a website at rortyrose.com
and i
spoke to those guys year-round
and they're
they're just humble really good people
and they want to feed you i'm telling
you right now they would love love to
have your business that's that's you
know that's one of mine i i
for so long for the first several years
didn't eat anything on site oh wow
i brought my own thinking i was saving
money and you know and again i didn't
bring much and then i'll be honest i
kept hearing uh campmates say talking
poutine they kept saying poutine and
you know i was too embarrassed to ask i
thought it was some
uh something obscene
they were making a joke and then i went
and had it and they haven't been back
unfortunately the the vendors um
but yeah the the food is great um
i i'm curious
uh
because of what you said
and and the camp rederoo guys and rewbus
i mean daniel has got so many things
planned there are going to be so many
many events within
bonnaroo i'm really curious to talk to
people in july and august
to see how it went you know what i mean
how it went actually went compared to
what they thought it was going to be
right well i think with the plazas
exploding this year
i think there's with so many bands
playing and
another shameless flood for people who
don't know rubus is having a wednesday
pre-party make sure you go to that hang
out with those guys they're fantastic
wonderful people
you won't meet meet nice for people at
least daniel paid me 10 bucks to say
that so i'm telling you right now
fantastic yeah he gave me five wait a
minute really
really hold on well he gave he gave me
10 but it was like it looked like
monopoly money but
i think he's good anyway right
but you're right they are super nice
people and that's that's what i mean it
that that event is going to be huge i
hope i hope he knows what's coming
yes
but it's not just that there are so many
other events and uh
you know as you said
we're all gonna and i've asked uh by the
way in case people are wondering i asked
when the lineups the actual schedules
coming out and
probably in the next uh i would say five
or ten days
if not sooner because it seems like
and it's not because of us necessarily
but it seems like as soon as i send an
official inquiry
to the people who should know
it comes out about it a day or two
they're waiting on you man that's what
they got yeah i don't know i don't think
it's that i just think the whole you
know
energy of the universe is thinking the
same thing so they're on it so we should
be getting that
but yeah that'll be the next fun is to
sit down with that thing and say i'm
going to go here i'm going to go there
and i'm going to go there and then you
get on site and you throw it in the
trash and you never see it again
but it's a lot of fun
you know
i'm wondering how
again you know where in the woods and
the stuff going on outside
the schedule this year might be bigger
than it's ever been just because there's
going to be so many different like
there's a band that i really want to see
on thursday the main squeeze i've
followed those guys for years and
they're not playing bonnaroo at all
except for out in the plazas yeah so i
definitely want to go see them so i'm
wondering how
many conflicts there's going to be this
year because there's going to be so many
different things going on
i i think fomo fomo could be the a real
issue
this year it always is as you said you
know we all think we're so afraid of
missing out
missing that show
and we all do uh but now
and it's so big
you know i can't imagine
i'm gonna see the what stage and then
i'm gonna go back out into the plaza and
catch this thing and then back
no you're not
right you're gonna have to make good
hard choices you're gonna have to make
some choices and and some of them might
be
you know instead of
thinking you're gonna bounce back and
forth i'm just gonna go
to this part of the the farm and hang
out and just see what happens
uh which is legitimate i i think with
all the events that they have planned
you could do that and have a great time
what we don't know is what jamtrax is
going to do if it's
if it's gonna be organized and big
enough that you know we could sort of
catch a ride and get from one place to
the other but man that's that's gonna be
the wild card i think that is going into
it that is either going to be the
greatest idea that bonnaroo has had in a
long time or it's going to be a cluster
you know what and
i don't know if that word's hyphenated
or two words or one word altogether but
that that scares me because
yeah
my fear is if if it runs well and they
run it great
then this could be a game changer
especially when it comes to plazas if it
doesn't run well then you could have
somebody that's in pod one that's all
the way over and pod seven and now
they're trying to figure out how to get
back and there's no transportation and
they're completely lost that's the one
thing that worries me yeah or standing
in long lines and all that yeah
absolutely it's a it's a terrific idea
and long time coming uh
but it's like everything it's got to
work well
um
all right man
taco you got any other questions you
know
i went one other shame i was gonna ask
and let you know i'm gonna let taco
i i do have one more shameless plug um
tuesday night uh
my buddy eric he is the official uh dj
of the pondo army he is doing a pre-pre
uh bonnaroo thing uh it will be in uh
our ga rv he's got two
uh fireball canopies set up and he said
you'll hear music coming there and he
spins and uh if you follow me again at
pondonknowsbest on twitter i will give
you more information once we know more
and i do have one final question i've
been asking everybody who's the one act
that i need to see this year and i'll
start with taco first
uh
i'm gonna you were talking about there's
a plaza lineup i'm gonna say paul coffin
um he he he did a thing with uh
what was his name orville peck
and i and i loved orwell pack i saw him
at chickadees last year
and um yeah they do they do a song
together and and his solo stuff is great
too and so that's actually one of the
ones i'm really looking forward to
seeing but he's gonna be i think it's a
thursday night plaza show
so yeah all right you're on the spot now
taco gave his give me yours
i know i wasn't expecting that i should
have i'm gonna go with goose right
i'm
i'm not gonna go with any of the names
that i assume you probably already have
on your list and goose might be on
though it is but that's okay tell people
who don't know
uh yeah goose they just they were the
ones that were on the uh
the uh online thing that they did year
and a half ago that uh
you know over that weekend there would
have been weekend and i i just thought
they were terrific briston um
not briston uh i've seen so many lineups
now i'm having to relook
the one i'm curious about is robert
plant and allison krauss
anytime you get to see you know robert
plant uh
you know it's like seeing a beetle
almost he's one of the legendary figures
well you know they played there before
oh yeah they did and i saw that same
show here in a in a theater
uh
yeah bristol maroney is another one that
i've i've become a big fan of
the one that i've been telling everybody
um
i'm going with the lesser know obviously
i would say the main squeeze but a lot
of people know who they are so i'm gonna
go with one that's a little bit under
the radar it's all going to be on the
who stage her name is charlotte sands
uh she's a young woman that's coming out
of the tennessee area and and she's got
a sound if she can get the right backing
behind her with her look
she has a chance to go places and plus
she's easy on eyes so you know that
makes it easier for guys to go see her
and she she's got really good vocals and
i don't know when she's going to play on
the who stage she may be up against some
heavy hitters but i really expect
charlotte sands to have a really good
show there
i i think the herbie hancock one's going
to surprise a lot of people yes
i'll be surprised how many people i know
want to go see that yeah people who
can't go uh a
couple of friends of mine up in new
jersey they just had a daughter named
violet and they know who they are if
they're listening and they can't go this
year and they said man we want to see
herbie hancock and i said well you know
when she gets a little bit older volley
will appreciate her being cocked too so
so yeah i think that's i think that's
sort of the lionel richie you know
obviously it's a legacy act but that was
lionel
as i've said was my
my uh
blunder
uh i think you could not go see lana
richmond no i thought liner was the
worst act they'd ever signed i i thought
bonnaroo had lost its mind and turns out
people are still talking about it it was
good it was good i've heard i've heard
and i think kirby's going to be like is
going to be that for a lot of people um
there's a bunch of them
but to your back to your point as we've
said on here many times thursday night
is a great night for discovery just go
and uh
you know
pick pick several people who actually do
that each day pick one name you've never
heard of or just if nothing else do a
walk by and give it a chance because
yeah one thing we've learned is
the folks who book these know what
they're doing
not everyone
you know
might be your favorite right but you
know they're good at what they do
correct and so give it a chance uh the
other one just because it's you talking
about shameless plug isaiah rashad
um is a chattanooga guy right and uh
i think we talked about
i think he's highest on the lineup from
chattanooga that that i can remember
he's on that third line on friday
um
so gonna definitely go see him
and uh glad to see he's on there so
yeah that's that's a good that's a tough
question you ask cause
you know i don't i don't always know
everyone else's
what they know and don't know i just i
just i mean even if it's somebody that
like goose is a great answer because
they are a band that play
so hard yeah and they're gonna give you
a performance even if you don't
necessarily and
think their music's your cup of tea
watching them perform definitely and you
need to do it you know it's yeah yeah i
mean we
somebody brought up uh one of my best
friends who i've known forever out of
the blue said man i can't stop listening
to courtney barnett
and i'm like yep that was a thursday
night fine for us
yeah i don't really know who it was but
i'm not much on country but i'm
way big on courtney barnett and just
just such
power and
her voice and her lyrics
man they hit you in places that
you ain't ready for if if you're not
prepared for it it it it could take you
to an emotional journey for sure and
obviously warren treaty we've talked
about on here leon bridges were both
those were both acts that i knew you
know the name
the show that i saw fell in love
and uh now
you know top
three or four acts of of all time for me
new acts right
so
you never know um
you know
one other thing bandit i think it's
really going to deliver and a lot of
people have made comments about them
playing is the chicks
i really think well orman knows the
dixie chicks i really think the chicks
are really going to bring
a grade a performance there i think
their set is going to be
pretty sweet i do expect a huge crowd
for that and even if you don't like
country i think you will like their set
so i'll tell everybody to check that out
obviously that's right yeah
you don't get very many people who just
mail it in right at bonnaroo correct um
very very few that i can think of there
have been some
but not many so
all right well man thanks so much thanks
for listening first of all oh thank you
definitely the what podcast it keeps you
in the know
uh it
you find out things that you didn't know
and the banter is pretty good and tell
brad he missed out hanging out with
pondo but hey you know that's okay
yeah we'll do it no tell he's unpacking
if that makes you feel any better yeah
yeah he would much rather be here
i wouldn't want to be doing what he's
doing
all right man well thank you so much
what are we under now uh in into the 50s
right 50 days or so 50 uh yeah
definitely less than three months yeah i
think it's around maybe a little bit
under eight weeks maybe a little bit
somewhere around in there you know
time to start packing
oh i've already got up my corner in the
front room and i have a bonnaroo pile
and it pretty much stays there year
round it used to be in there for like
three months then four months and now it
just stays in the corner like people
come and say what's that you move it now
it's a ponderous pile everything's okay
yeah cause if i unpack it it'll just
turn right around right all i gotta do
is yeah there's no need for all that
make sure that you know that the uh
the vermin haven't got to it there
aren't holes in something you need and
uh your tent poles are still there you
didn't use them for something else right
right right
thank you guys so much for having me one
more thing i do want to plug for those
of you doing the bottle roots dinner on
thursday uh i will be there as well
you'll be able to spot me i'm wearing
the viking horns
at the clock come by and say hi uh if i
have a mouth full of food let me swallow
first and then i will say hello to you
and i hope to see as many of you guys as
i can
on the farm this year for those of you
who want pondo army cards please do not
hesitate i'm easy to talk to i promise
you and the restraining order is just
another way of saying i love you so
trust me we'll get along
thanks so much man nope yeah sounds
great thank you
[Music]
consequence podcast network